[Music]
welcome everyone for the Tuesday evening
end game class and I prepare a few
positions to show you but I want to
start out with this position and a lot
of my previous lectures I mentioned
about this Bishop and night checkmate
method and I think many people want to
learn exactly how to checkmate so I will
show you a very easy way how to win even
though it may seem a bit difficult to do
but you will learn after this class okay
you're not gonna have this very often
this happening to you
but it's good to know how to win it so
the first thing you have to understand
this if you have a light square Bishop
you can only checkmate the black King in
their own a 8 or H 1 in one of these two
corners ok so that's the first first
thing you have to understand so step one
is to understand that if your opponent
is defending you know correctly he's not
just gonna go to this corner he's gonna
go to the dark color corner on h8 okay
so your first step is gonna be to push
his King to a corner okay so remember
that first thing you do you push the
King to the corner so I will show you
how to do that so you move up let's say
it goes here then you develop your
knight he will go back you get come
forward then you go Bishop check and you
go Bishop before now you put the [ __ ]
Bishop between this King and this King
so now he has to go back so you continue
doing that for a while and then again he
doesn't want to go to the center because
they can push it to this corner he's
gonna go to this side okay so I think
you should be able to to get this it
shouldn't be that difficult to get this
possession okay so 94 so he will go here
and now
basically put them in the corner so we
have our Bishop on a good position here
we don't want to move it so the King is
perfectly placed the next step is to
bring the knight to f7 okay because you
need a knight to control this square
that's the only way for you to do that
you cannot control this with the bishop
so you control this with a knight and
now he cannot come to g7 and h7 so he
has to go here so now it's our turn so
we have to if you get at this situation
you make a waiting move with the bishop
don't touch the king or a knight just a
waiting move he will go here and then
you go Bishop h7 so now you take away
this square so now he has to go this way
this is what we want we're slowly
pushing into this corner on h8 on al
okay
and now the first step is already
accomplished we pushed into a corner and
now we're next step is now to push into
a8 the only way you can do that is you
have to remember this idea W maneuver so
basically your knight is gonna move like
this so remember that okay so W maneuver
is very very important to remember okay
so that's the that's the key to remember
okay so so remember that idea so that's
why in this position you will start up
with a move Knight e5 that's the first
part of your W so he has two options
we'll look at both this or this right so
if they go here we go check pay
attention because then second time I'm
gonna ask you how to do this so make
sure you will be able to do this now you
move the King so see you always had to
control the square so he cannot escape
back so he goes here you go here now he
goes here
check again this is taken now you go
Bishop f7 square is taken and now you go
night c5
again the scores are taken sighs to go
here check and you get here that the
opposition get the King here check all
right so now all you have to do is bring
the knight to a6 so you go here you go
see you now you push wait with the
bishop he will have to go here now the
square is taken all the squares are
taken now you check now he is on a 8 and
Bishop a 6 mates okay that's one idea so
that should be the final position ok
take a good look at this position take a
picture of it if you want but that's the
way you will checkmate okay so let's
look at this other line that black can
try to do here very important because
again if you don't know what to do here
when they go can DL you can really spoil
this by the way you have only 50 moves
to win this in a real game okay and
there were incidents with very strong
chess players they know how to do this
and many incidents very strong players
they just never studied it and it was
very difficult for them to come up with
everything over the board so if T goes
here you have to go King D 7 here now if
he goes King yet you just go 97 and then
you're back to that first position so
they go King d7 now they're trying to
escape with the King okay and now you
have to find the right move to stop him
from escaping here so lets me ask you a
question here who knows the best move
here for white what would be that move
here to control a very important squares
so the King doesn't escape from the
corner you have 9 c4 but unfortunately
you're not controlling c6 square so I
can come up and walk walk up here you
know so what is the idea what is the
idea you can really try to do here yes
no no you have to control this squares
see he's trying to go to b6 if you let
him go to b6 that's it
his king is gonna escape from there okay
so you need to make a move 96 unfold 94
unfortunately laws this square and you
need to control both squares here okay
so what's the move here correct
97 remember you gotta control the dark
squares and you got a now use your
Bishop to cut him off now so he doesn't
escape and what which move is gonna do
that to stop him from coming in yes they
should be three perfect
now the knight is controlling this
course and the bishop is not controlling
this so he can do anything he has to go
back now one more cut okay now you're
gonna push him to the background so it's
like he made an attempt to escape but
then you pushed him back and now you
continue with your idea check now you
make a waiting move waiting move is very
important to remember you make a waiting
move and it goes here now yeah the
second part of the W maneuver you
remember the move correct if I go here
you just go Kings to six so I have to go
here continue mm-hmm okay
now put the King on a maximal position
and now now and now waiting move
remember remember waiting move everybody
should remember the waiting move check
this is sick so that's the final
position ok so it's really not that
difficult to to learn this ok so now
you'll learn this so I want to do it
like a practice with you ok
where you know you I'll ask all of you
just just to see if you can do it ok so
so what are the key steps to do this
remember so what was the first step you
have to do when you get this position
the very first step is first first you
have to understand that you can only
checkmate the King either on h1 or a
that's just the knowledge you understand
that so the first step is to do what to
make this work please raise your hand
yes push it to the corner any corner ok
if it goes to the light corner it's
perfect we made him right there you know
so pushing to the corner is the first
step what's the second step yes
ok by using which idea by using which
idea there is something remember
something in a shape yes W maneuver
correct you use the W maneuver that's
how the night moves right Big W remember
that movement of the night
ok there might be other ways to do it
too but the easiest way is to remember
the W ok and then you use the W to go to
the corner you gotta be accurate if you
let him escape one time then you're
cutting very close to that 50 move rule
ok so you probably still can do it if
you let him escape one time from there
but it's cutting it very close so you
don't want to do it all right let's
start now I'm going to ask you to
raise your hand and I'm gonna play block
you're gonna be white and I'm not gonna
be able to help you so you have to try
to win this okay so who wants to start
go ahead
yes kinky - okay I just showed you so
you know that the concept it's not that
difficult okay yes correct
and we'll count the moves at the end see
how many moves it takes to win next
always if you're trying to push him back
always go in front of him never go on a
side in front okay get the opposition
okay remember that opposition so it goes
here now yes
d3 use the bishop in okay and now what
else did I tell you about this when the
Kings are in front of each other what's
the best way to pushes him back put the
bishop between his king and your king
that's a very important idea to remember
because now you control the squares you
control the squares and the king cannot
go anywhere okay he goes here continue
okay
same idea we're using correct b5 King g5
is also possible but I can give her a
little bit better now if we move the
king then he has this f6 square so let's
control that square right better yes
because later on we're gonna go to f7 so
it's it's better to go from e for there
so he goes here
you could go 96 while we play King is
second both moves are good so it's not
that you have to do exactly this way
this part it's not that important you
can do other ways too the key is
actually to get this position like you
got this position now how are you gonna
push him from the black corner to the
white corner that's the key to
understand how are we gonna do that
please raise your hand
yes correct
what is the plan f7 and now the knight
on f7 is controlling that h8 square h7
square is controlled by the light
squared bishop okay so now what do we
call this idea oftentimes you're gonna
see we're gonna make this move what is
this idea called waiting move okay so
you have to remember the waiting move
idea it's it's no be surprised how
important is to do this waiting move in
endgame positions you'll be totally
surprised how important that is King f8
and now perfect you got it
and now what does this look like to you
W maneuver I would say probably one of
the most important things is to remember
the W maneuver that's probably the
crucial thing you have to do you know
they remember the W mine over the rest
you you should be able to do it so it
starts out with now there are two
options let's do both I'll start out
with this one the easy one
check right
remember gif King walks or King walks
remember that right it's like he walks
you get the opposition he walks you walk
to get the opposition now he's trying to
escape on f7 you're gonna let that
happen
stop it and now what kind of move we
need again what do we call that move
waiting move you could also go Bishop
age five but see for example if you
don't know that now you make any other
move you're gonna mess it up but maybe
five moves actually if you don't know
that so it's important to know this
waiting moves and ideas I mean again
you're not gonna have this every day
this is gonna be very rare you're not
even gonna have this once a year this
position but you have to make sure you
know how to win it King h8 now what we
do
if king c6 he goes back to the 8th which
plan we have to continue W maneuver W
right go ahead
you got it no it was here perfect okay
see Russian he went there what are you
supposed to do king b6 get it's like
opposition it's like some kind of an
opposition okay with the night between
the Kings remember the opposition now
he's trying to escape what do you do now
huh Knight c5 first get to the point and
then okay get to the point first and now
what we call this again waiting move
very good excellent I was very good this
is actually a lot of very high rated
players don't know how to win this this
is very important you guys didn't great
no I mean I have other positions but
let's finish this like and then we do
some other positions okay go ahead now
he goes king da do you remember this is
the tricky one I would say this is the
one a lot of people they will get
confused because it seems like it almost
seems like he is escaping from the the
back rank you know but how are you gonna
prevent him from doing that yes correct
now perfect
very nice look at that highlighted
squares huh
look at those highlighted squares he
cannot do anything now he has to go back
he's like he tried to made an attempt to
escape but you stopped him and he just
couldn't do anything so now he goes here
now very important move here
- totally push him back - totally push
him to the background yes what's the
move yes
no no no not to me
Bishop before remember centralizing the
bishop now he has to go back to the
background he goes here continue our
position right correct
okay okay all right
okay again don't rush with that move
just get the night in first waiting move
checkmate
Bravo very good everybody understand now
so if I have a dark square Bishop then
you have to is gonna go to the light
corner you just have to use the same
exact idea same exact method to driving
from that the light corner to the dark
corner to win okay so it's always the
color of your bishop okay it's always
the color of your bishop that that's
what you have to try to remember since
we're on this topic I feel like it would
be a good idea also to do the two
bishops let me ask you a question can
you do checkmate with two knights if you
just have two knights and he has a king
but that seems like a huge advantage no
six pawn advantage and you cannot win
aha excellent point yes if he has a pawn
I want to do one example of that okay
one example of that I just thought about
it then we'll do the bishops it's
amazing if you take the pawn off you
cannot win but with a pawn on the board
you can actually win this okay it's
actually made in five so please think
first I need you to calculate as much as
you can so it's wide to play again two
nights alone versus the king it's a draw
actually recently there was a game
between two strong grandmasters who
actually know the guy was trying to win
with white but what happened was he just
ran out of pounds and his opponent
sacrifice his rooked to the last pawn
and they just like each other like okay
it's a draw but so the guy with two
extra Knights wasn't happy because it
almost feels like it sounded unfair you
know you have this six pawn advantage
but you cannot win this so who can
calculate all the five moves in his head
and then raise the hand and say I have
the whole
think five moves it's actually it's only
one line it's not that many lines once
again if the pawn was not there on h5
it's just you cannot made him because
it's gonna be stealing in fact you can
made him but if it makes like a huge
blunder you know technically you can win
that position but that's in a require
huge blunder from him to win it okay yes
I can get every check he has to go to
the corner then you made it Knight f5
can you be more specific there are two
knights can go there which Knight H
that's each Knight hf5 okay we call that
now I say take my pawn take my pawn do
you want to take the pawn here you take
the pawn instant draw so you can't take
the pawn so what's the second move wait
wait let him finish
96 interesting doing a little bit
different way denied a but you can still
do it you still have that cushion to do
it you have enough time huh that's much
better now he's in a corner but he's
about to Queen you better hurry up one
two one two and I get a new queen here
you your knight movement was a little
bit not the simplest way but it was okay
you got you still got it
alright next yes 98 correct
I push there we go
excellent okay that's good
you could have also done this way you
know push or I would have just gone like
this you know a little bit simpler
enough boom and then
go here I just made okay I'm going to
change the position and I'm going to
change the position a little bit do one
more position since we're on this topic
I want to do one more position on this
it's it's not a difficult position at
all but I just want you to get this so
you actually have only one night here
okay
you only have one night here in this
position okay but here again his own
pawn is causing him so many problems
here that you can actually win this game
in just three moves white to play and
win it will only take three moves to do
that and that's not your best square
something a little bit better you have
there because your knight on f3 is not
gonna have checks anymore if you go
there so what's the move check he goes
to the corner right now what do you do
what do you do yes King g3 I escape and
you allow me to do that that's a big
mistake you can't let him escape from
the corner remember you got to keep him
in the box
King f1 now he can't go anywhere so it
has to go here what do we call that huh
summate yeah yeah animus I don't know
what's mother made it's it's just a mate
okay yeah it's it's sort of smother yeah
I guess it's boxed in so perhaps you can
call that smothered mate mm-hmm okay
very good okay all right let's go back
to the two bishops okay because it's
very important for you to know that okay
so let's say with two bishops it's much
much easier than the bishop at night
because you have the color of both
corners so you don't have to worry about
which corner you're gonna made him okay
because you have to both colors so this
is a pretty simple way to win and I will
show you how to do that okay so the
concept is simple you just move the King
forward and push the King to back rank
or a corner okay so let's say he comes
here right for something like this you
can give a check give another check
okay
now you know your bishops are
controlling a lot of squares so he let's
say if he goes here you have to you have
to be since the bishops are very strong
controlling a lot of squares you have to
be careful not to steal made by accident
okay I've seen that happening before
control the squares now he goes here
because right here if you're just not
paying attention you play this one
you're gonna still mate okay because you
know you just made a quick move without
think an estimate but instead the
easiest way to do is just go here just
just allow him to one square to go to
right here and now we already determine
we're gonna checkmate him in a corner
here right here this is where this guy's
going right here this square is taken
the square is taken the square is taken
so he has to go here now you want to
control this square how are you going to
do that
correct now remember if it goes down
it's same concept what did we do we go
down he goes here now he wants to go
here how are you gonna stop that now he
goes here what kind of moving it now
wait wait well actually yeah we can't
even do that yeah we can't even check so
he goes here you have to and now we need
waiting move right it doesn't matter any
move would be fine as long as you keep
this Bishop on this diagonal and now
show me checkmate in two easy very easy
okay
yeah because we don't have to worry
about doing the complicated the W
maneuver or anything it's the concept
you know concept is very very simple
okay and you just just simply follow it
through all right
let's practice that with you and see if
you got this I mean this is not the only
way to do it but I mean you get an idea
make sure you don't still maybe cuz
Bishop's are controlling a lot of amount
of squares and we can very easily still
mate
so go ahead
now I'm gonna care don't go here don't
go to h4 okay don't get one mistake it
will be costly you know but this is the
best way to do it that's the most
effective way to do it okay
correct he goes down you go down
remember he goes down you go down okay
that's the ideas okay now checkmate
no problem no problem well yeah I mean
you have you know six you know you know
bishops are just very strong because
they're both colors you have under
control okay so that's why it's very
easy to win okay
I want to set up one very important
position and which is a winning position
here and ask you to find a plan actually
the winning plan here okay it's like
it's this position basically white to
play and win huh so I've actually seen
two grandmasters play and the player
where the white pieces got to this
position but he just didn't know how to
put his opponent in a Suk's one you know
what sucks one means right well you put
him in a position with anything he makes
is just gonna make it worse okay so
let's see if he can figure out the sucks
one position here it's not that you're
gonna check check and win my rook it's
not gonna work like that if you think I
can just check check check check check
eventually I'm gonna win a rook actually
there is a problem there actually you
can even end up still mating
aha
so that's very good point you just made
like for example right you make the move
like this you think you got him and then
he goes check and that's gonna be very
very very bad for us
that's called steal mate okay so it's
still not too late to spoil the winning
position okay it's still not too late to
spoil it if you don't play the right
thing you know so let's see now he's not
gonna do that he's gonna go here check
see this is what I was talking about you
come here you feel like I'm gonna win
and then look at that with that still
mate
see ya trick ya if you don't know it
very tricky very tricky
alright you have to put him in a souk
salon yes Queen d5 no I mean you're not
gonna spoil anything by playing this
pool but I just don't see what do you
get after let's say I go here well
actually it could work sorry actually it
could work too actually but there is a
little bit more straightforward way to
do it
look you have to get a position where
his skin comes to a 7 you put a queen on
a square and then his King has no
squares to go to ok you have to control
the squares the king can go to you and
then he is gonna have to move the rook
away if they move the rook away further
away then you're gonna give checks and
win the rook
you usually you can get this even if you
don't know the concept you're gonna be
able to get a position like this when
you push them to the corner now the
thing you have to remember is this you
give a check okay he can't block with
the rook because that's gonna result
into a checkmate okay so he has to go
here okay and now you play the move
Queen d8 fantastic move now his King has
no squares to go to he can't go back he
can do anything if it goes here you just
pin him pin it to win it so he can do
that now he has two options to go either
to go either to here or here okay
in both cases if he goes to this moves
with the proper checks you're going to
be able to win his rook this is your
sucks one position so take a picture of
this position if you want this is the
key position you have to know the sucks
one okay this position is the sucks one
position if you're trying to win this
now if he goes here now you're gonna
have to connect with him either on here
or here to win the rook okay so the best
way to do it in my opinion is start out
with the cheque like this if he goes
here you just go check and the rock is
gone okay and you win easily so he
probably will go here now you give one
more check because you cannot go here
because you have mate so he has to go
here and now you give a check you go sin
and now connect it that's it
Queen p1 wins the game and the rock got
it
excellent and now if it goes the other
way it doesn't change anything
same concept go ahead check
if he goes here you go check rook goes
back here and mate on a one if you go
here you go check and you take the rook
he goes here now check that's actually
even easier this way you win the rock so
if it goes here you give a check and if
he goes here
now just mate on a four okay so the
first part to drive the King it's gonna
be pretty you should be able to get it
pretty comfortably but it's important
for you to know this idea of putting it
into a souk so on
okay that's the key position to remember
all right okay that's that's how you win
a position like this okay this is a very
neat King and pawn position you might
have seen this before or the same
position on the other side of the board
it's white to play and win well it's not
so surprising you drop upon and usually
in a King and pawn endgame that means
you're gonna be winning it but let's
think okay because it's not gonna be so
simple okay this idea is the only way
you can win this if you can somehow
maneuver your king and achieve the same
exact position with his move if you do
that what is that idea called I'm pretty
sure I mentioned it sound my lectures
this idea triangulation correct alright
let's see now how you can make this
triangulation work okay we know it's
triangulation but how are we gonna make
this work this triangulation
huh that's correct that's the first day
you know the rest okay okay
uh-huh correct so you triangulated it
now if he goes here who has a
triangulation we have the triangulation
now he goes here what do you do in this
case
no go forward promote the pawn he goes
here you push and now we Quinn right why
not
aha no no no rook checkmate in three now
who can do the checkmate in three Knight
yeah but you're making it more difficult
with the night let's think let's you
have three moves let's let's think let's
win in three moves that means mate in
three you can't put a bishop that's
still winning okay all the moves are
winning here except one more actually if
you Quinn you're gonna win but any other
move Windsor King f6 Bravo Bravo
he goes here yeah if you can make a move
and then promote it hook when you take
that okay you take that deal okay
and then checkmate so this idea is
called try on deletion got it that's how
you triangulate to win this so it
essentially you achieve the same
position with the opponent's move to
make then you win it okay okay to make
sure you understand this concept I'll
just do one more example of it for you
so you just same idea works here if you
make a wrong move now you can really
spoil this okay you can really really
spoil this so you don't want to make a
wrong move now you just want to find the
right move and then you win the game
white to move yes so just the same
concept as you did before
so what do you do yes
kingi - if it goes away you just push
and play g5 so it has to go here now
kindiy - King f3 year's King g5 you're
not accomplishing anything now he goes
here if now if it goes back with the
king you just take the pawn okay if he
goes here portion this portion
got it and you win it so again so the
idea was kinky - it goes here if it goes
there you just push the pawn okay then
he cannot do anything you woke up win
this pawn so he has to go here you go
here and achieve the same position so
the only way you can do that in a King
and pawn endgame where you use the
triangulation alai dia to get the same
position okay it's very important for
you to remember that okay you know in a
king upon endgame this idea of
triangulation there are some other
positions that we're going to work on
next few weeks a few weeks when I'm in
Saint Louis about n games and games I
really like them it's one of my
specialties and I grew up studying a lot
of n games you know we'll talk about
some other in-game position
you know concepts you know like distant
opposition regular opposition you know
and a few other type of position but
today one of the main thing was to learn
how to check me with a bishop at night
and I feel like you know all the people
here understood this idea I recommend
you practice this at home with a friend
or with somebody just practice at home
because you're not going to get to often
you know this position so practice will
help I'm sure you can probably do this
you know using some software as well you
know you can you can set up this let's
say in chess space if you really want to
know if you can win this set up this
against chess base and play against the
computer or chess comm probably have
that so just use that to practice okay
just practice because it's it's rarely
again it's not like a checkmate with a
queen or a rock
it's a rare so that's why you want to
make sure you get some practice so you
can do this okay
and the two bishops we did was quite
easy right very easy because you just
the most important thing is remember
it's not to steal mate that's probably
the only way that you're not going to be
able to win if you just still made him
okay because you know otherwise the
concept is pretty simple with the rook
positions we did was important to put
him into that suit
subong remember the King on c6 coined on
the eighth row combi 71 87 that concept
is the Suk's wonk and the King and pawn
n games with it like this is just
triangulation once again everybody
triangulation means what basically the
whole point of trying what is the whole
point a big picture of the triangulation
same position with upon its turn okay
excellent all right good job everybody
thank you for coming and we'll see you
Thursday okay
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]